assassin's creed mirage is real zelda
rumors are surfacing again and the halo
infinite feature is dead
following a handful of leaks ubisoft has
officially announced the next game in
the assassin's creed series mirage
unfortunately that confirmation is all
we're getting today and the company has
said that more details will be shared
during the september 10th ubisoft
forward for the time being though we
could just look at the leaked
information to get a decent picture of
what we can expect mirage will
reportedly star a young basm a character
from assassin's creed valhalla and will
show the events leading up to when he
arrived at the hidden ones the game will
do away with dialogue choices and the
ability to select a gender the game will
reportedly take place in baghdad in the
late 800s and will also be a quote
return to basics with no leveling this
back to basics approach is inspired by
2007's original assassin's creed a game
that ubisoft is allegedly making a
remake for this alleged remake will be
part of mirage's season pass and there
will also be constantinople dlc
according to the reports mirage will
launch in spring 2023 to be honest this
sounds like an assassin's creed i'm
going to be skipping i'm far from a
purist and i was really enjoying the way
that origins through valhalla was going
so to go back to the old way of doing
things uh it's just not it's not
something i want to do i don't know if i
can do it but either way on september
10th i'm gonna be tuning in to the
ubisoft forward because you know fomo is
real and if you're a nintendo fan then
you'll want to pay attention to the week
after the 10th because a source told
jeff grubb of our sister site giant bomb
that the next nintendo direct may be
held in the week of september 12th grubb
discussed the possibilities with mike
minatti of game speed and mike said the
rumored event will include the
announcement of wind waker and twilight
princess ports for nintendo switch both
games were already updated on wii u but
they haven't been re-released on switch
yet
whether or not this is a general
nintendo direct that includes details on
franchises outside of zelda remains to
be seen grubb went on to say that a
metroid prime remaster is also in the
works and could be announced at an
upcoming nintendo direct dear nintendo i
know you're watching i am prepared to
hand over a blank check
for wind waker on switch i will pay
whatever you want me to
just give it to me
give it to me now
but that's enough of my desperation for
a game i've never even beaten let's talk
about some halo infinite news halo
infinite developer 343 industries is
growing and improving the game in a
number of exciting ways but
unfortunately for some the promised
local couch co-op feature has been
canceled according to 343 it is choosing
to allocate development resources
elsewhere aka the game's live service
whether or not this is a temporary or
permanent shift away from developing
local couch co-op is unclear either way
it's a bummer especially because 343's
bonnie ross confirmed years ago that all
future halo fps games would offer local
couch co-op after halo 5 guardians
dropped the feature as for what is
coming to halo infinite the game's
biggest update ever the winter update
launches on november 8th it adds the
much requested match xp feature
thank god
a forge beta online campaign co-op and
more looking out even further season 3
echoes within is coming in march 2023
with the bandit rifle and more match xp
might get me back to playing halo
infinite i don't know we'll see come
november let me know what you think of
today's news stories and if you're
excited for zelda
halo or assassin's creed or all three
i'll see you tomorrow
you